chief washington correspondent major
garrett joins us now major thanks so
much good morning
good morning everyone i want to start
with those pardons obviously
controversial uh that we've been talking
about he
president trump touts himself as a law
and order president but
when you look at this it looks like he's
just rewarding loyalty
well certainly that's one interpretation
but the president and in the white house
statement you can read it very clearly
considers the entire
mueller investigation a miscarriage of
justice so everything he does
in terms of commutations or pardons the
white house asserts
is redemptive it is essentially
balancing the scales of justice because
as the president has said on twitter and
in public comments for years now
the mueller investigation was based on
fraudulent assumptions
the tactics used were abusive those are
the words the white house statement used
yesterday
and to the president's thinking roger
stone and paul manafort are therefore
victims though if you listen carefully
to paula's report they went to the
judicial process they were convicted and
in paul manafort's case pled guilty
and paul manafort lied to prosecutors
roger stone lied to congress what are
the common themes there
doing everything they can not to say
what they knew if anything about donald
trump
absolute loyalty how were they rewarded
absolute pardons
yeah absolutely um you know you see
these pardons happen
you also see the president escalating
tensions within his own party
he releases videos he's on social media
and then he just leaves town as we see
he's now in florida what do you make of
this
so i think one of the interesting themes
of the end of the trump presidency is
will this result in the crack up of the
modern republican party
because right now donald trump is as you
said jamie at war
with not just republicans in general he
is at war with the highest
echelons of the republican leadership in
congress this entire
gambit on increasing the amount of
stimulus checks after congress
has already not only debated it but
passed it with the okay and green light
from his own administration
so it's so late so late in the process
he's now
delivering a message to republicans in
congress i'm angry with you about this
and other matters
and i'm going to take my anger to the
ultimate political level we could have a
government shutdown
jamie next week on the verge of the new
year collapsing
economy raging pandemic and the
president could shut the government down
and republicans don't know what to do
and don't know how to react
and that kind of it's not even
intermediate it's chaos
yes but it's it's deeper it's much more
important than that chaos is something
we have come to
let us say acknowledge in the trump
presidency some appreciate it some
loathe it but we've all acknowledged it
this is much deeper this is about is the
republican party about donald trump
and his personal approach to politics or
is it about something
larger and more general well right now
that fight is playing out on multiple
fronts
and the person instigating that fight is
the president united states well that's
along those lines can you give us kind
of an inside look at what the mood is
right now inside the white house
well it's mostly vacant look there's not
very people at the white house and those
who are there
at the upper levels at the most senior
level are trying to keep the president
within some kind of normal guard rails
it's quite a challenge right now most
everyone else is looking for a job
because they know this is all coming to
an end the president has acknowledged
that won't acknowledge that but everyone
else at junior positions
has to find another job in washington
and try to find some way to gusty up a
resume
amid all of this that the president is
doing that's a challenge in itself major
garrett so good to see you thank you
thanks